hi everyone and hi Jamie great video on
Thursday if anybody in the audience
didn't see it I recommend you check the
link in the dooblydoo
if you didn't see that I also recommend
you check out his video on Saturday
which is outlining a new project called
ox tweet for those of you that don't
know ox tweet is a project where for one
week a variety of Oxford students will
be tweeting their lives on specific
Twitter accounts subjects which are
going to have these Twitter accounts
include PPE law engineering classics
biomedical sciences and medicine so to
find out more about that project check
out Jaime's video from Saturday which
will also be in the doobly-doo
alternatively search Twitter for hashtag
ox tweet also in your video on Thursday
you ask me the question what's the most
important lesson I've learned at uni now
that's a subject that I could dedicate a
whole video to answering but I think the
short answer would be whilst I've been
at uni I've briefed I've had experiences
that have made me really eight what I do
and why I do it and it's changed which I
think came about purely through the
tutorial system and having this
one-on-one contact with these
experienced academics who have gone
through this transition themselves and
they've had years of experience to think
about these kind of questions and it
comes to their own personal answers I
feel like I've taken a step further in
my personal development if you like but
like I said this is a very quick answer
to a very deep and meaningful question
that's very important to ask so in the
past week in my work I've been in
theoretical physics looking at stores
starting to look at interacting quantum
field theory whilst in atmospheric
physics we've been looking at satellites
and observing the earth different types
of satellite different types of orbit
and how you go about designing them
again it's kind of the real practical
side of the courses like if you're gonna
go out do science this is what you're
gonna do
the lecturer actually um had the best
example of spinning something I've ever
seen in my life when he was talking
about this project called the Mars
atmosphere orbiter and how he was
working on this project which
unfortunately crashed into the surface
of Mars because of a miscommunication
between two science teams and he spawned
this really embarrassing story by saying
that as a result I did work on the
project which got the first bit of
British equipment on Martian soil I mean
it wasn't one piece but you know on the
social side of thing
on Monday I went to a 21st birthday
party which was being hosted at a
cocktail bar in Oxford before we went
out to a club whilst I also went to a
yoga class on Thursday which is
something that's put on by the college
welfare officer so one of the elected
positions in the JCR is a welfare
officer who's in charge of various
things which are they designed to boost
morale or be somebody to talk to if
you're having a tough time I've never
personally had to take advantage of the
more serious side at service but yoga
class is the kind of thing that is nice
to do in your downtime and it's quite
relaxing and it actually means you're
going to work better in the future
because you're not stressed about
everything so my last video I asked you
guys where an Oxford you'd like me to
take my camera next and judging by a
couple of responses I got the impression
you wanted me to look at the physics
department so physics in Oxford is split
between three sites you've got the
atmospheric physics department and the
Clarendon laboratory on Parkes road and
the Dennis Wilkinson building on
keyboard now starting with the
atmospheric physics department
technically it is the atmospheric
Oceanic and planetary physics department
and it has what you'd expect a
department to have really it's got
corridors offices and elect theatres
where I have my atmospheric fourth-year
option Fletcher's the Clandon lab is
where amongst other things Henry Moseley
provided the experimental justification
for the atomic number these days at
houses research in atomic physics
ultracold atoms biophysics and a couple
of other small research groups it also
has the cafe that students can use and a
big lecture theatre where you have all
your lectures in first and third year
and some fourth your options and another
smaller one which is where you have your
lectures in second year and you may also
recognize as being the setting for
physics authority lectures the Dennis
Workington building which is named after
Sir Dennis Wilkinson he was a notable
nuclear physicist Oxford contains
research these days for nuclear or
particle physics and astrophysics it
also has a cafe and a lecture theatre
which is where I have my full theer
theoretical physics options lectures in
and houses the undergraduate teaching
labs now the teaching labs are split by
subject so there are labs for
again amongst other things computing or
programming in other words optics which
is kind of necessarily dark and
electronics and that's pretty much it
for the physics department short of
physically sticking my camera into
people's
that's about as much as I can show you
but if you'd like more information about
the research which happens and I highly
recommend you check out the Oxford
website which I again put in the
doobly-doo last but not least I have a
question for you the audience have you
decided on the college that you'd like
to apply to yet if so why and if not
what are you looking for in a Knox
bridge College answers that a nots and
Peter's College will be tolerated but
with a heavy judgment and my question to
you jamie is who in your time Oxford has
been your favorite lecturer and why
looking forward to your video on
Thursday and good luck to everybody
who's involved in the Ox tweet project